stimmt ist dass dubai kreisklassen
fahnenmast das habe ich öfter gelesen
die frage weil ich glaube dass ist schon
ist schon bekannt geworden oder so hey
leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
deutlich auf natürlich euch jedes gut
heute nach wirklich sehr langer zeit mal
wieder irgendwie meine stimme so ein
bisschen test test 13
auf jeden fall heute nach sehr langer
zeit ich muss sagen auch eigentlich
euren wunsch also ich habe total
vergessen das früher mal so fragen und
antwort wie deos total im trend warnt
aber ich habe auf jeden fall schon ewig
keine frage und antwort wie deo mehr
gemacht
warum auch immer auf jeden fall leicht
gerade davy videos auf youtube und jeden
tag 10 schreibt sich hinter die ohren
habe ich in den kommentaren gelesen alex
macht noch mal wieder anfragen und
antwort video und ich habe euch auf
instagram und auf youtube nach ein paar
fragen befragen und ich würde sagen die
schauen wir uns jetzt mal an und
beantworten die es sind auf jeden fall
interessante fragen dabei das kann ich
euch versprechen und das wird dann heute
halt so ganz entspannt ist fragen
antwort video ich hoffe ihr habt darauf
bog aber ich schon also deswegen machen
wir es halt auch schon mal relativ viele
fragen bekommen instagram alexy erste
frage von dakar
der spaß wird der nächstes auto seien
sehr interessante frage
ich habe gerade noch den mustern also
wenn jetziges auto genau dann habe ich
noch zehn monate dann gebe ich ihnen
voraussichtlich wieder ab oder fall
weiter aber ich denke dass ich ihn
abgebe und dann schaue ich mich mal nach
einem bmw oben also da bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher das ist ein bmw wird
welcher genau kann der ein oder andere
vielleicht schon erwarten weil ich habe
schon mal ein video dazu gemacht
allerdings dauert es ungefähr zehn
monate aber dann kommt ein neues auto
und freue mich schon sehr
aber ganz wichtig ich habe mir bis dahin
noch so ein paar ziele gesetzt
und bevor ich die nicht erreichen könnte
ich mir auch kein neues auto
das ist wichtig hey was machst du als
eine million special
leute ich muss ja sagen ich stehe jetzt
obwohl gut ich habe jetzt auch ich mache
jeden tag plus aber ich sehe jetzt schon
ziemlich lange zwischen 900.000 einer
million kann zwar gut sein dass ich die
eine million in den nächsten zwei drei
vier monaten
reiche wir werden sehen ich habe auf
jeden fall schon ein kleines special
geplant was ich auch schon seit über
zwei jahren hier und da mal wieder
drehen also ich habe so viele aufnahmen
doch wir schon gemacht allerdings kann
ich heute noch nicht wirklich zusammen
schneiden weil ich die eine million doch
nicht erreicht habe deswegen ganz
wichtig für euch abonniert jetzt alle
mal den kanal weil dann geht es um so
schneller wenn jetzt mal angenommen
dieses video 80 bis 120 tausend leute
schauen
und davon haben mich immer so ich kann
es ja in den statistiken sehen immer nur
so 35% abonniert da muss jetzt einfach
der rest den kanal abonnieren und dann
haben wir es ja schon ganz einfach
nachdem eine million special können ja
noch wieder sehr abonnieren es war ein
bisschen felder und ja das gab es schon
mal derart in youtube ist eine million
special oscar und und hatte danach dann
wieder neun und hat irgendwas 1000 wird
warum machst du keine gaming videos
finde deine videos aber mega das habe
ich schon sehr viele gefragt ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin halt also ich
zocke an fifa so aber ich bin kein
vollblut gamer und mit dem was ich hier
auf youtube mache habe ich schon genug
stress und allein auf dem hauptkanal
jeden tag ein video zu machen ist schon
immer eine herausforderung und vor allem
auch immer voraus planen die ideen zu
finden da bleibt wenig zeit für ein
gaming kanal weil ich ja auch noch
andere dinge in meinem leben tun von
denen viele von euch glaube ich gar
nicht wissen wer der tag ein bisschen
länger und ich hätte bock auf gaming
videos will ich auf jeden fall auch
gaming videos machen oder reaktions
videos habe ich ja auch mal angefangen
aber das frisst so viel zeit aber seit
auf jeden fall gespannt was alles noch
so kommen wird weil ich jetzt bald in
köln ihr vielleicht auch ein kleines
büro umziehen werde
und da kann ich mich dann auch besser
auf die sachen konzentrieren und da
helfen wir dann bestimmt auch ein zwei
leute bei den ganzen sachen die ich für
youtube instagram und alles mögliche
machen und vielleicht besteht da noch
die möglichkeit noch andere sachen zu
tun hier auf youtube ist so glücklich
mit marie bin ich super glücklich dank
für die frage - ich bin sehr glücklich
wie maria riesch oder grüße du bist die
beste
normalerweise wird jetzt auf dem bett
sitzen und mir zu gucken aber die ist
gerade nicht da also das meistens so
wenn ich hier die videos drehen dann
kommt auch und zu mal ein kommentar von
recht wie findest du die darsteller für
die videos zum beispiel hilft mir
darstellerin
ach so das ist darauf bezogen weil ich
ja in letzter zeit öfter mal so kleine
interviews mache mit einer ehemaligen
mcdonald's mitarbeiterin wird eine hilf
mir darstellerin burger kann
mitarbeiterin frauentausch kommt auch
noch glaube ich ja der ist er ist und so
und ich muss sagen
also es ist immer recht entspannend so
ich denke mir auch manchmal ok
hoffentlich ist die person cool weil es
gibt ja auch viele persönlichkeiten dann
total schüchtern sind vor der kamera
wenig sagen ich kann zwar so sagen ich
hatte bis jetzt eine schlechte erfahrung
mit einer persönlichkeit die gesagt hat
dass mal wieder machen und dann ein
bisschen komisch war im nachhinein ist
auch egal ich will jetzt auch niemanden
irgendwie bloß stellen oder so aber es
kann natürlich schon vorkommen dass
manche personen ein bisschen komisch
sind
ich kann ich allerdings sagen mit
einläuten worauf das video online
gekommen ist die waren super nett und
man hat sich auch gut verstanden vor
allem pascal mit dem ich ja zwei videos
gemacht habt bei ultra cool mit dem habe
ich mich echt sehr lange über ganz viele
verschiedene themen unterhalten und ja
das ist für mich wirklich immer
interessant und es macht mir spaß wenn
ich jemanden abholen und dem fall fragen
stellen kann zu irgendeiner serie wo
aber mitgespielt hat oder irgendwas was
er bis jetzt in seinem leben gemacht hat
nächste frage stimmt ist dass dubai
kratz klassenfahrten machst das habe ich
öfter gelesen die frage weil ich glaube
dass ist schon bekannt geworden oder so
krass klassenfahrt ist ja diese youtube
serie von jonas und dem anderen jonas
und die haben mich tatsächlich gefragt
ob mario und ich nicht lust haben damit
zu spielen also pärchen falls ich das
jetzt schon sagen darf na das passt auch
sonst und ich kann es sehr gerne sagen
ich freue mich auch schon darauf ja ich
spielen dabei mit und zwar jetzt von mir
gerade freitag ich weiß nicht wann
dieses video online kommen allerdings
fliegen wir am mittwoch nächster woche
mittwoch nach warschau nach polen
warschau aus die hauptstadt von polen um
dort die vierte staffel zu drehen und
ich freue mich sehr darauf wieder schöne
super coole zeit und ich strenge mich an
das ist auch coole folgen werden und ihr
daran spaß habt ich weiß nicht ob jeder
von euch das guckt oder das kennt auf
jeden fall lohnt es sich da mal
reinzuschauen
wie gesagt wir spielen damit es wird
verrückt ja das kann man so sagen also
verrückte rollen ich heiße julian und
sie heißt julia falls ihr das noch
wissen wollte warst du schon mal im
urlaub und dort haben sich zuschauer
kann
ja das ist in der tat von häufiger
vollkommen gerade auch wenn man dann
halt im urlaub ist und da sind ja auch
mal viele deutsche touristen also ich
wurde logischerweise immer nur von
leuten angesprochen die auf deutsch
waren außer einmal da wurde ich wirklich
von spanien angesprochen die mich
erkannt haben aber nur weil ich
irgendwie so einem in story gemacht
haben die dann mit sowie sagten geo oder
standort versehen habe die haben es dann
gesehen oder okuma hier also ich
irgendwie so hat und ich meine da bist
du das nicht nicht soja und halt nur
deswegen so weil wir sonst halt immer
nur deutsche aber es kommt halt
eigentlich schon so irgendwie immer wenn
ich egal wo ich im urlaub bin ich war
das ist ja im november und dezember ja
in amerika in los angeles und sogar dort
wurde ich zwei mal angesprochen und
beide male bei innen out burger halb von
deutschen die ihr dort essen waren also
in den augsburger so eine riesen
burger-kette da das war echt krass so
komplett auf der anderen seite der welt
gefühlt und sonst halt mein spanien ist
oder so kommt es auch manchmal vor ist
jetzt nicht immer so aber schon vor
kommt genau aber es war echt cool also
das freut mich sehr heiß ist die youtube
was ist da muss ich jetzt noch überlegen
jetzt heißt es die youtube in einer ich
sitze jetzt schon eine minute nicht
verleger also von dem größeren so
mißfelder finde ich also ist auf jeden
fall ne hübsche den finde ich noch
hübsch also tut mir leid ich habe es mal
ein bisschen gesucht ich weiß nicht also
die wird mir direkt einfallen ansonsten
jetzt verstehen wir auch so ein paar
kleinere youtube in die auch hübsch sind
aber im final keinen namen ein irgendwie
komisch
tut mir leid falls du oft serien guckst
würde ich gerne wissen welche deine drei
favoriten sind also was wirklich so mich
in den letzten jahren total fasziniert
hat und ich bin sehr traurig darüber
dass ist vorbei ich hab damit vor vier
jahren angefangen das zuschauen game of
thrones und habe mich super auf die neun
tisch war dass die neue staffel die das
war die achte staffel habe mich sehr auf
die achte staffel gefreut jetzt leider
auch schon vorbei ist also das war eine
serie die ich in den letzten jahren sehr
verfolgt habe es war eigentlich so meine
lieblingsserie was ich da noch geguckt
habe war haus des geldes auch eine geile
serie mein magen
und vielleicht so ein bisschen was
anderes ich gucke grad in serie heisst
das mittelmeer
da geht es um das mittelmeer
die landschaften und wie sich das alles
entwickelt hat finde ich auch
interessant also das könnte man
vielleicht als meine drei lieblings
serien bezeichnet ansonsten habe ich
auch prison break breaking bad alles so
ein bisschen geschaut walking dead und
so aber das hat ja irgendwie jeder eine
frage haben wir noch welcher fußballfan
bist du also an alle die sich für
fußball interessieren ich muss sagen ich
bin super großer fußballfan also ich
schaue eigentlich fast jedes
fußballspiel wenn ich es schauen kann
also vor allem in deutschland spanische
liga englische liga war folglich auch
alles nationalmannschaft natürlich auch
ich habe ja auch selber lange fußball
gespielt habt dann jetzt aufgehört als
nach köln gezogen bin leider also ich
vermisse es schon ich bin auf jeden fall
also es hat sich so jetzt in den letzten
fünf jahren entwickelt hier um die ecke
ist das stadion von fc köln
also schaue ich mir gerne an also ich
bin auf jeden fall immer für köln wenn
köln spielt allerdings muss ich sagen
dass ich heute mal gesagt ich bin dort
wo ein sympathisant aber ich kann mich
mittlerweile schon so als dortmund fan
eigentlich ein bisschen auto weil ich
finde die spieler die da spielen vor
allem marco reus gehört zu meinen
lieblings spielern gerade wie sich die
mannschaft sondern letzten drei vier
jahren entwickelt hat neu aufgestellt
hat so das weiß ich nicht also ich bin
immer für dortmund und ich freue mich
immer sehr wenn die gewinnen und ich
kann ihnen auch dieses jahr mal die
meisterschaft also wer auf super wichtig
für die bundesliga an alle fußball
fanatiker da draußen also ich bin sehr
großer fußballfan sagen wir mal so das
war's mit dem video
hast du nach oben da schreibt gerne
weitere fragen die kommentare wenn ich
das noch mal machen soll
und ich hoffe es hat euch unterhalten
wir sehen uns morgen wieder um 19 uhr
gibt es ein neues video das war es von
mir morgens ihr normales videothek
instagram abo die den kanal ducati
werden haut rein